to meet somebody who you follow on
Twitter and whose work you respect and
you read and then they are kind enough
to say hey I'm gonna be in Los Angeles
which not everybody does and then they
show up here in studio and I will stop
talking about these people like the this
gentleman is not sitting in my right
long time investigative correspondent
for a decade and a half for the New York
Times now a senior investigative
reporter for espn.com and ESPN The
Magazine Don Vann now - good to see you
Don great to see you rich thank you how
many of my colleagues at the NFL front
office is seeing me sitting with you
right now and saying oh come on probably
more than a few you think so yeah I
think so as you and Seth wickersham have
wrote i've written a couple of long-form
pieces for espn.com that have really
ripped the lid off on a lot of the
conversations that owners have been
having behind the scenes on the kneeling
during the national anthem front as well
as the commissioners contract so let's
start with that last one first what what
is Jerry Jones is mood right around now
best you can tell Don I think he's I
think he's trying to put a good face on
a on a bad few weeks Jerry Jones really
was in a tough spot you know earlier
this year back in May at the owners
meeting in Chicago Jerry Jones was one
of 32 owners who voted for Roger Goodell
to have his contract extended Jerry
Jones for years has been Roger Goodell's
Key cheerleader on lots of different
issues on on the deflategate issue Jerry
Jones was out there saying Rogers doing
a great job
he backed him on the Ray Rice scandal
and then suddenly the Ezekiel Elliott
thing happened in a Seth wickersham and
I reported just a couple weeks after
Jerry Jones voted for Roger Goodell to
have that contract extended he had a
conversation Jerry Jones had a
conversation we could Dell and came away
from it believing that Goodell was going
to let Ezekiel Elliott off the hook on
those domestic violence allegations
Jones told everybody in Dallas that and
then in August they had a follow-up
conversation in which Roger Goodell said
no I'm gonna suspend Ezekiel Elliott for
six games and at that moment Jones said
to him as Seth
reported I'm gonna come after you with
everything that I have and he tried to
this fall it was really a war over the
contract and I think that Jones hurt
himself in a way with a lot of his
fellow owners because they saw it really
through the prism of Jerry Jones's anger
over the Ezekiel Elliott punishment and
not Jerry Jones's issue with a lot of
other problems at the nfl's now having
with ratings with merchandise sales
going down and so yeah I think Jones is
putting a good face on this Goodell got
his contract extension for a lot of
money and and Jones's is still trying to
wave a victory flag over what was
clearly a loss for him a very rare one I
mean well I mean in in that regard
though he he and from what I read as
well has not given up the fight or at
least that's what he's giving the
impression of behind the scenes would
you say that that is accurate
I do think that's act so then what does
that mean it means that Jerry Jones is
gonna try to make Roger Goodell's life
difficult in the coming years
Jerry Jones believes that there's not
enough transparency with what the legal
office does he feels like some of his
fellow owners by the way that the league
office itself is bloated and has been
ineffective he's particularly angry
about the entire apparatus that's been
set up to do these investigations that
he feels distracts fans is not good for
the game certainly wasn't good for the
cowboys with what happened with Ezekiel
Elliott with the six game suspension but
he thinks there's too much emphasis on
that and he doesn't like no he's just
he's tired of the bad headlines that
have occurred now that this has happened
what he can do going forward is continue
to rally owners to the view that Roger
Goodell needs to do more he needs to do
a better job the irony is this guy got a
five-year contract extension for a lot
of money but he's had a pretty rough
three years since the Ray Rice scandal
Goodell and and and yet you know the the
owners stuck with him and Jerry Jones
was really pushing on a closed-door he
was one of really only five owners that
felt that they should look elsewhere for
another Commissioner right Don Van Natta
of espn.com ESPN The Magazine the
invested senior investigative reporter
here in the Honda inside a report
here on the Rich Eisen show and then you
know
so basically Jerry Jones this was all
because of Ezekiel Elliott that if
Ezekiel Elliott had only gotten maybe
one or two games or zero games
none of the arguments that he had
posited about what may still be the case
about the National Football League he
would not have done that
Leslie what you're saying that's that's
that's what I'm implying yes let me be
clear
different implying insane yeah let me
clear the rich because if you talk to
Jerry Jones about it he will say that
that's not the only reason that he had
concerns about Roger Goodell contract he
felt that the whole process there was
not enough transparency was led by
Arthur Blank the owner of the Falcons
the compensation committee and Jones was
a sort of unofficial member of that
remember he threatened to sue because he
didn't like the way was going that he
got kicked off the committee he would
tell you that he didn't like the process
he felt that the contract was really
rigged that even if metrics continued to
go down for the NFL that Roger Goodell
would still get paid that's what Jarrod
Jones would tell you if we were sitting
here was his biggest concern but the
timing of it as I explained is quite
coincidental that after he heard that
Ezekiel le was gonna get that six-game
suspension when he was absolutely
certain he was off the hook then Jerry
Jones was very vocal about all of these
problems and issues he had but the
contract process and with with Goodell
would you call it ironic then that it's
entirely possible that by a week from
Sunday the team that could prevent the
Cowboys from going to the playoffs
because they have a tie-break against
them in port hence potentially bad
record is Arthur Blank
yeah the Atlanta Falcons and he was the
head of the Compensation Committee that
Jerry was trying to stop even though
when you said he voted to give the
Commission of the contract they voted to
give the compensation correct full carte
blanche to do what they felt it needed
to do to get the commissioner they gave
the authority to the compensation
committee that's a Howard Howard how's
that relationship as you can the
relationship was very strained I mean
when when the Falcons and the Cowboys
played in Atlanta about a month ago
about a month ago
you know Jones and blank stayed on
opposite sides of the field they didn't
talk to each other you know it's
customary for owners to come and greet
each others was a
wild scene yeah I ain't normally they
are all you know it's it's it is the the
term for it and I learned this when I
first started with the NFL it's the
membership that's right they're not the
ownership they call it the membership
that's right because they're members at
a very exclusive club it's it is may be
the most exclusive club in America
and that's right and they and they they
share everything they share profits
they're all on the same side most of the
time but this was this was a moment
that's rare where Jerry Jones is anger
at blank you could see it it was it was
obvious they saw each other at the
meetings just a couple weeks ago in
Irving or last week in Irving Texas and
blank said to Jones are we okay and
Jones said we're okay
but there's still a lot there's a lot of
tension there nobody thinks that right
yeah nobody thinks that how does it
manifest itself I know I'm returning the
question Don Van Natta senior
investigative reporter Honda inside a
report how'd it because at some point it
all leads to a collective bargaining
agreement conversation that's like
everything I mean all of it a player
compensation player safety player
discipline commissioners right to
discipline all of that is maneuvering
Epps towards what's happening in a few
years from now that's right correct yes
okay so and I and I think some of these
you know these spats will probably be
repaired by then because that's the ball
game right and and and you know rich you
raise a really good point a big reason
why Roger Goodell got reuptake you t'v
who said you know what we're not pleased
with Roger Goodell overall job
performance but we want him there in
that room when the next collective
bargaining agreement is up because of
what a great job that was done in 2011 I
mean the owners steamrolled the players
back in 2011 and the owners want that
result again and it's trust the devil I
know over the devil I don't know and in
terms of you know his contract it was
reported and stated that this is gonna
be the commissioners last one right as
best you can tell as they're already
maneuvering as to who's gonna take his
job in 2024 literally seven years from
now Don yeah and I would be surprised if
Goodell is there to the very last day of
of his Contras that right yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if we see the
commissioner after the collective
bargaining agreement is struck and asked
2021 correct correct and after we have
the new television hopefully by the way
hopefully right if we don't have a
strike or a lockout right or
interruption in the game that's a little
too much inside a report I don't even
want to go there
right but but I think that in 2022 or
2023 we may see Roger leave early he's
made noises about that with some people
close to him and yeah there was
maneuvering just this fall there was
another problem that Jerry Jones had in
his push for looking beyond Roger
Goodell is well who is there there's not
a deep bench in the NFL officer was not
an obvious candidate there
the usual names came up Condoleezza Rice
has said it would be a dream job of hers
to be the NFL commissioner her name was
mentioned a couple of other names were
mentioned other names what are you
hearing uh you know I'd rather it's
called inside you know there there there
were a couple of other names but I don't
think they ever got any traction you
know as Seth and I reported Adam silver
the NBA commissioner somebody but one of
the owners had an emissary reach out to
see if if he would be interested
interested and and very quickly said no
and what's remarkable about that is
think about that the the NBA
Commissioner doesn't want to go over to
the NFL job because the NFL job has so
many problems I mean the NFL is in it is
in a is in a tough spot right now on
many fronts but you know that can and
because that's one way to look at it
another way is that Adam Silver's got a
job at the NBA he's doing a great job at
it it's very successful there that
doesn't mean that the NBA is more
successful than the NFL know or that you
want to buy stock in the NBA more than
the NFL you know I'm trying to flip it
you know all I'm saying though is I
think I think that Adam Silver's job
where he is is an easier job than if you
were to move over the NFL almost lost
conversation here with Cuban it's a good
Reinsdorf I mean I'm sure there's enough
of a pit over there for the lack of a
better phrase I want to take a break
back in 60 seconds to discuss the
ratings front on the NFL whether you
really do
believe the NFL is in ratings trouble
and then there's a case in front of the
Supreme Court that could change the game
for all sports because sports gambling
could be legalized in in on many forms
Don Van Natta that was the Honda inside
a report here on the Rich Eisen show and
I just want to make sure that you all
know that the happy Honda days sales
event is going on right now the best
time to get a great deal on a Honda is
right now but you have to hurry because
unlike the snow ball in your freezer
these deals won't be around forever see
I'm using lines around a rudder like
that but Don Van Natta back with Don in
60 seconds okay welcome back to the Rich
Eisen show at ESPN senior investigative
reporter Don Van Natta returns here for
another segment before we return to the
sports world when you were at the times
with the New York Times
what were the stories that you worked on
there that you was going to say these
were the ones that I'll remember or I'm
glad around my resume and what people
will discuss the impeachment of Bill
Clinton I was in Washington for six
years so I covered the impeachment of
Bill Clinton and Monica Lewinsky scandal
in 1998 2001 I was there for 9/11
actually heard the plane hit the
Pentagon for my house in Alexandria
Virginia and covered counterterrorism
out of London for The Times from 2003 to
2005 which was a great experience I also
covered the phone hacking scandal the
Murdoch phone hacking scandal in the UK
2010 2011 so why'd you decide to you
know what I'm gonna leave the hard-news
world behind and going to the sports
world I had a great opportunity you know
I was a frustrated would-be sports
writer rich I wrote two books about
sports while I was at the Times and I
got this opportunity Chad Millman called
me in the summer of 2011 and asked if I
would be willing to join ESPN and kick
the tires on that and it looked like a
great opportunity I've had just nothing
but fun yeah when I went when I was at
that at Medill School of Journalism at
Northwestern my-my professor in the
quarter where we went to Washington DC
and became correspondents for local TV
stations used us as their local
correspondents cuz I guess we were cheap
labor and plus it was great experience
for us Lou Prato is his name he's a big
Penn State University football historian
anyway he would always say you know
Eisen why do you want to work in the toy
department he would call the sports
world
toy Department would you agree with that
that's what it's called it is the toy
department but I felt there was such a
great opportunity for me as an
investigative reporter to do sports
investigative reporting I felt it was a
pretty open playing field there were
only a few people in the country really
that got the resources and the time
necessary to really dig deeply into some
of the subjects at ESPN has allowed me
to do so for that reason it really was
it's the toy department but it's about
politics it's about culture it's about
race you're writing about all the big
issues that any news reporter is writing
about and you know the money is huge the
stakes are huge the egos are even bigger
it's just it's a it was a great
opportunity so what do you think
returning to the first topic of
conversation that we had before we do
move on to sports gambling and the TV
ratings of the NFL about the kneeling
during the national anthem
obviously that became literally a
political football yeah how do you think
this is gonna play out based on your
reporting and what you know for the 2018
season well it's gonna be interesting to
see what the owners do at the Winter
Meetings in March Jerry Jones this fall
again was at the forefront of this issue
he pushed hard for there to be a league
wide ban on any players kneeling during
the national anthem that didn't get much
traction with folks back in October at
the athlete meetings at the Conrad hotel
in lower Manhattan I think there's going
to be renewed discussions about this in
March though I don't think there's going
to be enough owners that are gonna want
to mandate it because it can backfire it
being back fair very easily and very
quickly you know they're in a bind
they're in a tough spot I think the fact
that the owners have basically reached
out and tried to have an honest open
dialogue with players and the players
coalition and to try to put a big amount
of money into these causes that they
want the sign they're rich is with a
little bit of a wink and a nod of a quid
pro quo like if we give you the NFL
platform to help on these criminal
justice issues and really try to make a
change as well as put money to the
causes that you want hopefully that will
be enough for players no longer to take
a knee during the national anthem I
think if you asked owners behind a
closed door they would tell you that's
the result they think is best for the
business
and for the game but if you talk to play
they're not willing to necessarily give
up a constitutional right to kneel and
to protest just for a paycheck and I
talked to fans okay and and and there
are fans who call this show who have
served militarily or and as a first
responder or say it's the players right
to do that and I have some who are on
the others the up I don't want to say
side okay but there are those who say
that the players should stand up okay
that this is not the time to utilize
employees lats right their employees and
and but all that said there is the
narrative that's out there that this
issue that we are discussing right now
donphan not a senior investigative
reporter of ESPN is the root cause for
the lack of rating spikes that that that
the ratings are down and part of the I
saw I don't know what his name is some
conservative talk show host put a
photograph of the Browns home game this
past weekend and said this is what
liberalism does okay and no mention of
the O and 13 or 14 right exactly but you
see what I'm saying is that this is
being utilized used or is it an accurate
portrayal based on what you were seeing
about the ratings in the NFL Don I I
don't think it's the the main cause I
really don't I think that the
controversy hasn't helped already we saw
a softening and ratings last year it was
chalked up by some folks in the legal
office to the presidential campaign and
and because of course the ratings went
up somewhat in the second half of last
year well I do remember there was a
Sunday night game in a Monday night game
and one involving Aaron Rodgers Neal I'm
adding another involving breeze and and
Ryan in a league where you know
obviously first-string top flight
quarterbacks are becoming rarer and
rarer they went up against two of the
three debates right so I do remember
that are these ratings taking into
account streaming I mean I saw an
article in The Wall Street Journal that
they are not they're not and that that
that's definitely a problem because
that's how a lot of fans are now getting
the games they're getting them on their
mobile phones and on their iPads I think
that the anthem issue definitely didn't
help but the saturation
of you know oversaturation of the of the
product is a big problem the Thursday
night football games have been awful
this year um there's so many injuries
there's so many marquee players that are
out so you put all of these into the mix
and they're they're all issues and
they're and they all are you know
depressing the ratings I do have to Don
Van Natta point out there was a 4139
Rams 49ers game on Thursday Night
Football that Carson Wentz beat Cam
Newton on Thursday Night Football they
were they weren't all awful you got a
point one or two that were but right now
I do say and I say from this microphone
in this seat that the oversaturation is
a problem I do this for a living if I
did not do this for a living and I have
a wife and three children at home as I
do and I have as you see this Michigan
Wolverine helmet on the desk so that's
one window of football that I am
definitely going to utilize as a dad and
a husband I'm gonna definitely watch
Michigan and then if there's three other
college football windows and five six
depending on whether there's an early
London game windows of NFL football from
Thursday to Monday um how much football
can somebody watch right and live their
lives
yeah and how special is it you're right
I mean on those London days at 9:30 in
the morning
Eastern Time until midnight you've got
Pro Football on the red zone channel is
another factor of course a lot of fans
are just watching that there's no
commercials on that you know they're
dipped in a little bit sure but but
there's but there's no ads for that
I think the oversaturation is really uh
the biggest issue I think talking to
owners and executives that's what
they're seeing it as and it's something
they're gonna have to deal with the you
know Thursday Night Football you're
right not all the games have been awful
that was unfair to say that but most of
them have been and they've been some of
them have just been unwatchable some of
the Monday night games have not been
terrific either and there's too many
games it doesn't feel special doesn't
feel like appointment viewing anymore
even on Thanksgiving you know there's
that now there's the Thanksgiving night
game remember how great it was when we
were growing up it was just not Dallas
and at and at Detroit those two games
and now you've got a third game it just
feels like it's too much last one for
you darned
ESPN senior investigative reporter the
the suit in front of the case in front
of the Supreme Court about sports
gambling what should fans know about
this and how do you think it will play
out and change the way that we've used
sports if it comes to pass here
legal experts who know a lot more about
this than I do say that they feel there
is a better than 50% chance maybe a 60
or 70% chance it's the Supreme Court is
going to rule in favor of Governor
Christie and New Jersey and they will
believe will be legal sports wagering in
New Jersey if that happens I think we
will see a quick domino effect of other
states there's already states that have
made preparations for this like
Pennsylvania Mississippi several states
very quickly within several years you'll
see 15 to 20 state legislatures around
the country legalizing sports wagering
that's gonna turbocharged the ratings
it's gonna turbocharged fan interest
again in the NFL in a way that we can't
even imagine and I think that's what
we're gonna see but the league is
pushing back against our right that
that's what's that's what's so
interesting rich because of the long
tradition in the NFL that anti weed
anti-gambling tradition in the NFL and
Goodell is still there they're pushing
back they're pushing back you know
against this in the Supreme Court but it
will help them they see how fantasy has
helped them I mean just imagine what
legal sports wager will do in half the
country two-thirds of the country what
it would do for interest in the NFL fans
will be stick until the last second of
every game to see whether the over-under
hits I mean it'll be a different
ballgame Don thanks for coming in again
I really enjoy your work I follow you on
twitter glad that now we have met face
to face come back any time let me know
when you're in Los Angeles do that thank
you we got it check out Don Van naty's
work and follow him on Twitter at dvn
junior-junior
on twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience